hola buenas noches mi nombre es maría am
villaescusa lo pone ahí soy actriz
dramaturga y directora de teatro y
además imparto clases de teatro a niños
y adultos hace dos años pues
también me llamarían villaescusa no me
he cambiado el nombre tenía solo 29 y me
costaba mucho decidir que era actriz
aunque tenía la misma formación que
tengo hoy
tampoco escribía no dirigía
y me dedicaba a dar clases a niños y
adultos para llegar a fin de mes
igual no veis mucho la diferencia entre
hace dos años y ahora pero yo sí porque
hace dos años dos años justos tal día
como hoy un 17 de octubre de 2017 un
radiólogo del hospital cogió a mis manos
y me dijo que el bulto que tenía en el
pecho era era un cáncer
imaginaos como me quedé pues no recuerdo
haber llorado tanto en mi vida pero
estoy contenta de estar aquí hoy con
todos vosotros celebrando mi segundo
aniversario de vida
pero muy muy contenta
así que nada los compis os
qué ha pasado en estos dos años pues
pues han pasado muchas cosas las
principales que me curado y estoy aquí
como ya he dicho y la segunda es que ha
prendido un montón de cosas la primera
cosa que aprendí le aprendí creo que
unas 24 horas después exactamente del
diagnóstico sentada en el sofá de mi ex
casa cuando vi a mi ahora expareja
hacerse las maletas recogerlo todo y
salir por la puerta y dejarme y ahí pues
ya sentada en el sofá diciendo ya no me
puede pasar nada peor me viene una frase
a la cabeza y me vino así como como una
luz como la que tengo ahora encima y fue
esta frase
la vida es aquello que te pasa mientras
tú estás ocupado haciendo otras cosas de
jonh lennon
una frase que yo pensaba que entendía
pero entonces me di cuenta de que no lo
había entendido hasta ese momento
que estaba haciendo yo hace dos años
pues estaba haciendo muchas cosas pero
en el fondo no estaba haciendo ninguna
porque todas las cosas que hacían el
foto eran cosas mentales eran planes que
yo tenía en la cabeza planes del tipo me
voy a casar
voy a tener hijos mi futuro marido
ganará mucho dinero y yo podré viajar y
mis hijos ganarán más dinero que yo y
serán mejores que yo y yo igual con
suerte soy una mejor mamá de lo que he
sido como marianne
y cosas así así que todo eso era un poco
irreal en el fondo no estaba haciendo
nada
no no estaba haciendo ninguna cosa en
especial entonces claro no era feliz
pero yo no me daba cuenta y lo decía
gran antonio machado verdad caminante no
hay camino se hace camino al andar'
y ahí empecé a entendernos
como podemos
vivir un proceso negativo pues
diseccionando lo y viviendo lo paso a
paso como decía machado ahí está nuestra
verdadera verdad es lo que tenemos que
empezar a hacer y yo me encontré con que
de repente estaba enferma y tenía que
aprender a hacer todas estas cosas me
convertí en una paciente en una paciente
paciente porque yo hasta ese momento era
muy impaciente no os podéis imaginar y
claro si tú intentas vivir un año de
enfermedad en el mejor de los casos que
es un cáncer
así como me curo ya con una fecha pues
no hay una fecha tienes que vivirlo paso
a paso pensando en el día de hoy que es
lo único que tienes tiempo
tenía un tiempo que si no había dado no
sabía cuánto iba a durar no sabía se
saldría de esta y tenía que vivir ese
proceso pues pasito a pasito
el tiempo es oro o no el tiempo es vida
y ahí yo lo entendí lo entendí de verdad
que solo tenían aquí y el ahora y que
tenía que pensar que quería hacer con
ese aquí y ahora
así que me propuse vivir me propuse
vivir cada angustia cada tristeza cada
momento de viaje de bajón cada brazo con
mi madre cada larga espera en la sala de
un oncólogo vivirla y de verdad que
cuando abrazas ciertas situaciones están
tan horribles a simple vista pues al
abrazar las de hacer las tuyas pues se
desvanecen un poco
el ser humano es extraordinario y es
verdad y también aprendí a vivir mejor
pues cada momento de felicidad que era
entonces muy muy muy auténtico
bienvenido a que deciros eso que el
mejor año de mi vida empezó con un
diagnóstico de cáncer que es un poco
raro de decir pero pero es verdad
pero no he venido aquí a hablar del
cáncer porque pues porque no he venido
aquí a hablar de eso por qué
solamente sobre una cifra podría decir
que las cifras estiman que 1 de cada 3
personas padecerá un cáncer en su vida
si no le pasa otra cosa antes o que una
de cada ocho mujeres o diez mujeres
sufrieron cáncer de mama como yo y más
en un mes como este que no sé si sabéis
que dentro de dos días es el día del
cáncer de mama y hay una ola de ping
washing que son productos dos rosas con
un lacito para que compréis para que se
dé dinero se destine de investigación
sin embargo otros cánceres como el
cáncer de próstata que es igual de
masivo pues no veo que nadie se ponga un
lacito azul ni compréis productos azules
no voy a hablar de estas cosas de verdad
porque tampoco soy una experta yo he
venido a hablaros de cómo vivir un
proceso negativo y transformarlo en algo
no sólo llevadero sino en algo positivo
quizás en la frase de esa de si la vida
te da limones pues anti monada
pues eso
y yo dije bueno pues si los limones
están claros tengo un cáncer mal igual y
ahora pues mi exprimidor
pues ahí es cuando comencé a creer en mí
misma entonces mi exprimidor mi
catalizador fue el arte el arte escénico
en este caso el teatro
y así de un día para otro casi y no sé
cómo empezar a escribir una obra de
teatro una obra de teatro cortita
autobiográfica en la que yo contaba a mi
manera todo aquello que me estaba
pasando era una comedia además sea era
hasta divertida
no sé qué voy a hacer con esto pensaba
bueno ya encontraré justo en aquel
momento salieron las bases para el
festival russafa escènica que se celebra
en este año cada otoño y dijo pues me
voy a presentar hoy a presentar este
proyecto que es lo peor que me puede
pasar que me digan que no ya lo tengo el
no verdad
y me seleccionaron y así pues nació mi
obra
se llama siles pues es el nombre porque
me dio la gana la verdad se llama match
y cuenta este año de mi vida los que me
conocen saben que te lo cuento tal cual
soy sale mi tumor también que es otro
actor no habla porque los tumores no
hablan pero está ahí y es muy guapo
no estaba tan feliz estrené esta obra un
mes justo después de acabar mi
tratamiento de acabar la radioterapia
no pensé nada más que en estrenarlo y
ser feliz con mi pequeño equipo éramos
cuatro personitas que yo hoy tres más
que me ayudaban
y de pronto en aquellos 14 pases de una
obra de 30 minutos se empezó a llenar se
empezó a llenar se empezó a llenar la
cola me llegaba hasta la puerta yo no
sabía qué pasaba yo me llamó un poco
igual de bueno si no cabe en que se
aprieten no sea
era feliz era feliz y todo importaba un
poco y lo último que me espere después
de tanta felicidad y tanta catarsis es
esto que me dieron un premio pero qué
dices en serio pues si el jurado del
festival decidió premiar me con con el
premio a la dramaturgia que el premio
era una pequeña dotación económica para
que yo alargará esta obra y esta obra se
convirtiera en una obra de largo formato
en una obra para para teatros
para teatros como este porque justamente
aquí en este mismo teatro se estrenó mi
obra en versión larga hace unos seis
meses y ya digo bueno esto se me va de
las manos que está pasando de repente
tengo mi propia compañía de teatro que
se llama la intensa
que además hemos estrenado a otro
proyecto hace poco
además de todo lo que he dicho ahora soy
empresaria si lo pienso también me he
dado cuenta
y no voy a estar más contenta pero mira
si los espectadores de la sala además
decidieron que el espectáculo se llevará
al premio del público que es lo más
bonito que te puede pasar
aquí ya sí que la vida no para de darme
regalos
algo tan malo era uno de los mayores
miedos que yo tenía que era tener un
cáncer creo que igual alguien más de la
sala le puede pasar me pasa y yo con
esto me he curado y he podido hacer
todas estas cosas ahora creo en mí ahora
no tengo miedo a presentarme a concursos
no tengo miedo de ir a un casting no
tengo miedo de hacer una entrevista de
trabajo y aunque sí antes tenía un miedo
horrible así que saqué todo esto y
aparte me curé
así que estaba feliz super feliz pero y
siempre hay un pero
no os he contado el pero el pero fue que
al mismo tiempo que se estrenaba esta
obra en versión corta pues me dieron el
alta médica lo cual es maravilloso y yo
pues tuve que volver a trabajar
y de pronto era como agua guau guau
qué está pasando aquí el mundo va muy
deprisa yo me había bajado de esto tenía
todo el tiempo del mundo para meditar
para leer para escribir para quedar con
una amiga tomar el café para quedar con
mi madre y hablar con ella a todo le
decía que sí porque claro no sabes
la vida entonces adquiere otra dimensión
y a todo el mundo le dices que sí
y cuando te curas tienes más ganas
todavía tienes ganas de bailar de salir
de reír de amar y al mismo tiempo que
sientes esas ganas
vuelves a trabajar y de pronto mi
jornada laboral crecía crecía y crecía y
crecía
y yo no supe decirle a todo eso que no y
de pronto mi horario se vio desbordado
un momento qué está pasando aquí no tú
te habías prometido a ti misma que ahora
te vas a tomar las cosas con
con otra velocidad si vas a vivir de
otra manera pero
pero no lo hice
y la verdad es que no no sé todavía muy
bien cómo salir de esta situación de la
situación de la vida moderna de esto de
levantarte a las ocho para media hora
para comer seguir trabajando volver a tu
casa a las nueve de la noche cenan has
puesto la lavadora vuelve tan
presión ha ocurrido una cosa
es decir que no
bueno parece raro no es una palabra muy
fácil pero
me ha dado cuenta de lo difícil que es
al menos para mí decir que no
como digo que no tengo miedo a decir que
no sigo aprendiendo a día de hoy a decir
que no cuando he identificado que el
problema de mi vida es ese
si quieres ser feliz tengo que aprender
a decir que no así que cuando veo que
algo no me está haciendo bien cuando
siento una insatisfacción aquí otra vez
una presión en el pecho o me enfado o me
frustro pues intento pararme donde sea
aunque sea en las escaleras del metro y
me caí cinco minutos y respiro e intentó
localizar aquello que no me está
haciendo feliz
y cuando lo localizó si lo consigo pues
entonces digo vale que es lo peor que te
puede pasar si dices que no a esto
y la respuesta nunca me parece tan
terrible
así que estoy intentando crear un método
para decir que no con dulzura con
amabilidad y siempre con una sonrisa
y aún no me sale muy bien la verdad
pero yo sigo ahí porque me dado cuenta
de que la vida
la vida es aprender nada más que eso así
que ahí estoy
aprendiendo
pero me sigo equivocando claro
pero al menos ahora sé que mi vida no es
una equivocación
y acabaré
esta charla diciendo
si la vida te da limones are limonada
pero no te laves vas tú todo reparte una
poca
[Aplausos]